في تطورات جديده ومتسارعه في القضيه اللي
تناولناها امس في حلقتنا قضيه بلوجر
المصريه هدير عاطف واللي بعد ما طلعت
ولدتها في فيديو بتبكي وبتصرف واعلنت
اختطافها من قبل بلطجيه واستغاثه وطالبت
بانقاد بنتها وطلع زوجها او طليقها مو
عارفين لسه ونشر سوريات مو مفهومه عن
ارصده وفلوس واختفاء وهدد كمان بالانتحار
بعد كل هذا طلعت الداخليه واعلنت القبض
على بلوجر ازياء وشقيقه زوجها وزوج شقيقه
زوجها تبين انه هدير عاطف او تبين ان فعلا
هدير عاطف مثل ما توقعوا الناس وبيان
الداخليه يتكلم عن 16 مواطن مقدمين شكاوى
ضد هدير وزوجها واخته وزوجها بتهمت النصب
والاحتيال التطورات انه طلعت ولدت هدير
عاطف ووضحت الامور وكاله انه بنتها ضحيه
بسبب طليقها وملائم وقالت انه هي
كانت تعرف ان الاشخاص اللي جوه واخذوا
بنتها هم من المباحث وانا فكرتهم الاشخاص
اللي بيهددوا بنتها من شهرين بسبب المبالغ
الماليه اللي اخذها زوجها او طليقها منهم
وما رد لهم هي ولا اعطاهم الارباح والنصب
عليهم واكدت انه بنتها ما بتعرف ايش
بيشتغل زوجها ولمن عرفت انه بينصب على
الناس طلبت الطلاق والطلقت وكلام الام
اكده مو حامل بلوجر اللي كمان طلع وقال له
اللي تم القبض او تم القاء القبض عليها هي
هديل وانا ما لها علاقه باللي جالس بيصير
وانه تم القبض على ثلاثه من المتهمين ولكن
طليق هدير بلال ديب لسه هربان امه عارفين
وينه ولكن في نفس الوقت محاميات مجموعه من
المجني عليهم قالت انه هي من شهر ما تشوف
القضيه ومعاها مستندات وثائق بتثبت انه
هدير الطرف يعني عمليه النصب هذه وفي
محادثه بينها و هذه روبن بلال طليق هدير
او زوجها ما احنا عارفين لسه زي ما باقول
لكم وحوالات بانكيه والمنصات ووسائل اعلام
مصريه بتتكلم ان الفلوس هذه اشترى فيها
الزوجين فيلا وفي كلام كمان عن سر وجمعها
بلال من العملات المشفره اللي ممنوع
التداول فيها في مصر اقيل انه رصيد وفيها
354 مليون دولار وكلام متفاصيل اخرى كثير
مو معروف حقيقتها وعموما ومن اقل من ساعه
السلطات المصريه طلعت بيان اعلى ناس في
القبض على زوج هدير وحبسه هو واربعه اخرين
امرتنيابه القاهره الجديده بحبس زوج بلوجر
هذه العاطف اربع واربع اخرين اربع ايام
على ذمه التحقيق بتهمه النصب
والاحتيال على مواطنين طيب معنا عبر
الهاتف محامي البلوجر هدير عاطف الاستاذ
محمود السمري اهلا فيك معنا استاذ محمود
هل في عندك تفاصيل جديده على اللي ذكرنا
اليوم
تفضل استاذ محمود هل عندك في تفاصيل جديده
في القضيه هل تعلم هل في تحقيقات جديده
طلقه هي بلال برده عشان خاطر العلم بلال
كان زوج البلوجر هدير وتم التطبيق بتاريخ
25/11
ما هو بيان نيابه كان طالع على اساس
الحاله العامه اللي ظهر قدام الجميع
والراي العام اللي هي فعلا كانت زوجته لكن
الطلاق تم بتاريخ 25/11 على النيابه
العامه ما طلعت البيان طلعت البيان على
الحاله القائمه قدام الجميع هي ما كتبتش
ان هي قالت الحقيقه اللي هو زوجته ان احنا
امبارح قدمنا وثيقه طلائها بتاريخ 25/11
بس البيان النيابه كان طالع كانها لسه
عددته طيب خلاص وضحنا هذه النقطه طيب فهي
طليقه
تعليقات الطريق 25 11 هي متوجه لها
اتهامات هي واخته وجوز اخته بالاشتراك
معاه النصب والاستيلاء على الاموال من
الناس بحجه تشغيلها واستثمارها
هدير بلوجر عندها بلورز وصل 2000 جنيه 2
مليون 600 بحكم من شهرتها وزوجها برده
بلوجر بس مش بنفس شغلها بنفس شغل العريضه
الازياء ابتدى يشتغل في الاستثمار فهي
متهمه الاشتراك معه لكن هي طبعا انقرض حته
علمها ان هو بيستثمر فلوس الناس وياخذ
الفلوس
عند ادله علمها بالموضوع ومحادثات
قديمه
الناس اللي هي دفعت فلوس لبلال زوجها لكن
كان تبرير وكبريرنا النهارده جديد زوجها
فاي احد بيكلم زوجها تليفونه مقفول كانت
هي بترد على التليفون ردك على التليفون
خلي الناس تحس اللي هي شغاله معهم لكن كان
نوع من انواع الترويج لعمله ده ما حصلش
اكونت بتاعه تحت هيشغلها عارضه ازياء
على حسابها ولا مره قالت انه مثلا انا
زوجي عنده هذا النوع من الخدمات او انا او
حطت رقمه او اي شيء من هذا القبيل خالص هي
بتعمل شغلها لكن اللي بيتصل على تليفون
زوجها
يعني واحده ما تعرف نشاط زوجها
هي هي بتقول نشاط زوجها نشاط استثماري
استثمار في العقار والسيارات والبورصه هي
دي اللي عندها علم بيه اكثر من كده هي ما
تعرفش اي حاجه عن حته اللي هو ممكن ياخذ
الفلوس ما يرجاش وبتفعل في بعض الضحايا
قالوا ان هم كانوا بياخذوا ارباح يعني حتى
امبارح في الطرقات قدام النيابه قبل ما
يخش كنا بيقولوا احنا اخذنا ارباح بس هو
توقف عن الارباح فهي زوج بها ايه زوج بيها
مش همم مكيده فيها لا هي تورطت في حته
اللي هي مشهوره وزوجها عمل كده وهرب اما
هرب ما فيش غيرها النيابه العامه
الطليق خلينا نسمي الامور مسميات على بما
انه انت قلت انه طريقه
تحقيق معه
هو غالبا النهارده لازم يتعرض لان
النهارده معنى اللي هدير اخذت اربع ايام
على ذمه التحقيق يبقى لازم تستقبل
التحقيقات معه لاني في الايام اللي جايه
لازم يبقى في مواجهات مع الضحايا فهو لازم
النهارده يتعرض وهو اكيد بصدد العرض الان
واخته وزوجها
دول تم التحقيق معهم امبارح واخذوا اربع
ايام ولكن هل في ادله عليهم كمان هل عندك
اي مستجدات تخصهم هل قالت هدير انهم على
الاطلاع بالموضوع
في الموظفين فابتدا يستخدم اخته وزوجها في
الرد على بعض العملاء والتحويلات الفلوس
ما بينهم الى ومنهم منهم واله
على العموم احنا بنشكرك على هذه المداخله
وهذه التوضيحات واكيد خلال الايام القادمه
يعني هتتوضح الامور اكثر من كده نحن
بنشكرك على هذه المداخله كان معنا محامي
البلوجر هدير عاطف الاستاذ محمود السمري
شكرا لكم